this spring when Russia invaded Ukraine
fertilizer prices increased in some
cases 400 percent and Global grain
shipment sputtered our farm didn't feel
anything because we don't buy fertilizer
and we don't buy foreign grain
suddenly our years of being marginalized
by the agri-industrial complex inverted
and interest in our methods and Madness
exploded
both farmers and non-farmers begin
asking
how do we disentangle from the system
just in time the darling inventory
phrase of recent decades changed to just
in case as supply lines fractured
culturally a society detached from
menial life tasks like Farm chores and
kitchen duties suddenly found itself
vulnerable to unforeseen fragilities
the food and farming sector goal
switched from efficiency
to resiliency
in the spring of 2020 as covet's Black
Swan permeated the world store shelves
went bare Farmers euthanized that means
they killed and threw away millions of
chickens turkeys and Hogs because Mega
processing plants couldn't maintain
operations
at our house we neither worried nor
feared because we had freezers full of
meat and a basement full of canned
Garden produce I don't see all this
proudly I say it gratefully and as a
challenge to everyone Freedom comes from
participation
we've spent a couple of generations
exiting historically normal tasks and
behavior from integrating livestock and
crops growing gardens buying locally and
cultivating domestic culinary arts we
even abandoned breastfeeding for a
couple of decades
we thought squeezable cheese and
subcontracting kitchen duties to Mega
corporate entities replacing
decomposition with chemical fertilizer
honey with refined sugar and butter with
hydrogenated vegetable oil would launch
us into a new Freedom Nirvana
but instead it Shackled us
enslaved us to nefarious scientists
bringing us fertilizer and menus from
Laboratories instead of from God's
ecological womb
those of us who continued to participate
in historically normal Farm chores
Garden production local or biologically
grown sustenance and domestic culinary
arts are today
enjoying more Independence and freedom
you cannot have freedom without
participation
here are two questions to ponder first
would America's food system have
convulsed us violently If instead of 300
Mega processing facilities employing 5
000 people apiece we funneled our food
through 300
000 Community scaled 20 to 50 employee
facilities
the second question is when Rocky
disruptions affect our ship of state
would you rather navigate dangerous
Shoals in a maneuverable speed boat
or an aircraft carrier that takes 10
miles to turn around
let's examine what a food and farming
parallel universe would look like by
juxtaposing current objectives with The
Lunatic Fringe alternative
I've got 10 of these
number one
cheat food versus precious food
if one thing defines American
agriculture it is dedication to cheap
food
American per capita expenditure on food
is the lowest in the world our per
capita expenditure on Health Care is the
highest
cheap food promised to give a spendable
cash to attend football games and
casinos and cruises and movies
it created a love affair with
concentrated animal feeding operations
cafos that became incubators
for disease
floating on a sea of cheap energy these
facilities promised mechanized farming
and pharmaceutical health
sub-therapeutic antibiotic use created a
world of superbugs like MRSA and C diff
a brand new lexicon burst on the
American vocabulary campylobacter
listeria E coli salmonella food
allergies type 2 diabetes these are
nature beaten and abused on its knees
pleading and begging enough
instead of God's designed decomposition
driving fertility petroleum-based
chemical fertilizers substituted like an
intravenous feeding tube replacing
edible food in short our agriculture
System created a dead zone the size of
Rhode Island and the Gulf of Mexico
infertile frogs and three-legged
salamanders and now our life expectancy
is dropping we're addicted to
Pharmaceuticals physical and emotional
maladies plague our nation
perhaps
most damaging effect is on Farmers
themselves the primary custodians of our
natural resources not to mention food
feel marginalized and unappreciated
when's the last time you heard with a
school guidance counselor advising Mary
you're really sharp with great grades
and honors credentials you should be a
farmer
burdened with the unnecessary and
ridiculous responsibility of feeding the
world American farmers now number fewer
than our prison population
it gives me pause to realize that my
book you can farm would have
had a much bigger buyer interest if it
had been you could be a successful
inmate
stewarding our air Soil and Water with
our best and brightest will only come
when we have a precious food policy
that's up to Consumers not farmers
can you imagine a cheap religion policy
a cheap Road building policy
a cheap Information Technology policy
dear folks you cannot abdicate precious
food respect without serious
consequences as a culture we must leave
this cheap food universe and get in the
Escape pod of precious food
number two quantity versus quality
bushels and tonnage are all we measure
by every metric over the last century
nutritional quality plummeted today you
have to eat three times as much broccoli
to get the same nutrition as you did in
1940.
our farm participated in a pastured egg
nutrient study several years ago the
official USDA I call it the US duh
nutrition label
for conventional Supermarket eggs list
folic acid is 48 micrograms per egg
our polyface eggs averaged 1038
grass-finished beef has 300 percent more
riboflavin than grain finished
pasture livestock offer much higher
percentages of conjugated linoleic acid
indeed only two weeks of grain feeding
chases it out of the body on beef cattle
the bionutrient food Association is
documenting the wildly disparate
nutrient content of various Foods in
carrots for example they found that you
would need to eat more than 10 carrots
of the worst to get the same nutrition
as one carrot of the best
to my knowledge nobody in the
conventional food and farming sector is
seeking better quality they're just
trying to fill bins and trucks doesn't
matter if it's junk
we can all thank Austrian biochemist
Justice Von liebig for beginning this
downward Trend when in 1837 he told the
world that all life is simply a
rearrangement of nitrogen potassium and
phosphorus in pek
replacing the Magnificent
complex relational biological community
with simple chemicals denies the human
microbiome its optimal sustenance
sir Albert Howard who developed the
scientific aerobic composting method and
brought it to the World In His iconic
1943 book and agricultural Testament
wrote quote artificial manures that's
what he called chemical fertilizer leads
inevitably to artificial nutrition
artificial food artificial animals and
finally to artificial men and women
unquote I would add who can only be kept
alive with artificials
a functional authentic agriculture
requires a focus on quality
number three segregated versus
integrated
segregated versus integrated throughout
history agriculture required a highly
integrated approach because until cheap
energy and mechanization distribution
was laborious you couldn't pack more
animals in a house than you could bring
in feedstocks and haul out manure by
draft power indeed from 1900 to 1910
with the Industrial Revolution well
underway along with rapid urbanization
newspaper editors and city planners
feared Metropolitan implosion dependent
on draft power to haul in fodder and
Livery supplies and haul out manure
cities were sinking under
transportational inefficiency
poop covered the streets it was on your
shoes when you went into the bakery
Travelers drug manure into hotels
patrons carried poop into restaurants
on farms the same constraints required
Integrated Systems crops required
proximate animals in order to receive
the blessing of their manure
in 1946 the average morsel of food in
America traveled only 40 miles from
field to Fork today the average is 1500
miles and we've gone from a calorie of
energy per calorie of food to 15
calories of energy to a calorie of food
we've become that inefficient or looked
at another way that segregated
no longer dependent on Nature's
fertility we mine our fertilizer from
far away places to be placed on land
that grows crops to be fed hundreds of
miles away to animals that are trucked
to Mega processing facilities for
packaged food shipped to the Costco near
you
meanwhile the historic blessing of
manure becomes a liability clogging our
streams and poisoning our groundwater
because it's too much in one place for
our ecological womb to metabolize
sir Albert Howard also envisioned
Diamond cities and predicted water-based
sewage systems would Fade Into
obsolescence by the 1960s he imagined 25
house developments placed in a diamond
shape so each Diamond each one would
have access to passive solar heat the
one acre inside the diamond would employ
a Master Gardener and composter who
would collect the human excrement each
day compost it and grow highly
nutritious fruits and vegetables to feed
the 25 households surrounding the garden
isn't that beautiful
our college campuses
should all have a chicken house attached
to the back door of the dining hall
so kitchen scraps can be converted to
eggs on site
all roofs can be guttered to cisterns
equipped with pumps operated by exercise
bikes in the fitness room
students could exercise by pumping the
water back up on the roof which would
grow vegetables that would Cascade Down
the Walls for fresh picking from dorms
and classroom windows
the vegetated roof would cool the
buildings enough to eliminate the need
for air conditioning the systems would
eliminate the cisterns would eliminate
storm water infrastructure the campus
would be divided into quadrants and each
day students would waken to an app
notice telling them where fresh
blackberries apples or strawberries were
ready for picking and the students could
graze their way across the campus
all buildings would have attached
solariums generating passive solar heat
and growing cool hearty leafy greens all
winter eliminating Trucking from
California
the campus that institutes these simple
low-tech improvements will be a Beacon
of Hope and help to a world wallowing in
hopelessness and helplessness
could it be Hillsdale
number four
centralized versus decentralized
people assume that to feed the world we
need big things big chicken factories
big combines big fields
no we don't
a lot of little things can out compete
one big one I appreciate big and smaller
subjective terms and by U.S duh
standards our polyface farm is now a
large farm but compared to Tyson we're a
drop in the ocean on our farm scaling up
is not about centralization it's about
duplication the difference is profound
the average American Farmer is now 60
years old in the next 15 years 50
percent half of all agricultural Equity
is going to change hands that's Farmland
equipment and buildings no civilization
has ever seen that big a change in
ownership in peace only in Conquest like
the Huns rampaging Rome now I'm not
suggesting the U.S is getting ready to
be overrun by the Huns maybe we are
maybe we aren't
but what we're seeing in the
geopolitical agricultural landscape is
unprecedented any business book will
tell you that when the average
practitioner of any vocation or economic
sector is more than 35 years old that's
a sector in Decline
in agriculture is now 60. this
successional problem isn't because
farming is obsolete it's largely due to
the cost of entry for the Next
Generation when young people can't get
in
old people can't get out
for example if a young person learned to
grow chickens for Tyson
the first item on the agenda is a half a
million dollar building
would you call that an impediment to
entry
compare that to our pastured poultry
model which requires a 10 foot by 12
foot by two foot high floorless box
containing 75 broilers that's meat
chickens move daily across the field
all you have to do is cancel your
Netflix subscription for a couple of
months and you have enough cash to build
one and enter the chicken business
if you like it you can build another one
with retained earnings if you love it as
much as we do
over time you can build more than 200 of
them debt free Dave Ramsey would be
proud
America has roughly 35 billion Acres of
lawn
and 36 million Acres housing and feeding
recreational horses
we can spread production over thousands
and thousands of places not a single
confinement Animal Facility is necessary
we have millions of Acres locked up
on our farm pastured pork and Forest
house pigs using high-tech electric
fencing and moved every few days
exercises the ecology and eliminates
concrete fans and Despicable manure
lagoons
people who Embrace pod schools
homeschooling and educational co-ops
know that centralization which is akin
to institutionalization does not a
better education make the same applies
to agriculture
spread it out
democratize it
entrepreneurialize it